all right
lada and elena
yes yes you guys are both from ukraine
yeah we are from ukraine we were born
there
and uh we
were living there all our lives you were
friends in ukraine yeah but you found
you came here separately
yeah to the us uh first i came through
tijuana and then lada did also the same
thing because we were unsure how safe it
is because mexico is kind of really
unsafe place
for being there especially if you're
white and blonde but you were able to
come to the united states how through
humanitarian parole
it's a shelter for people who
in which countries
there is war going on
and uh
yeah so we literally came to american
officer and we asked for humanitarian
parole and let us in so it's not like a
visa
or anything like this it's just um
temporary it's a temporary
arrangement for people in your situation
yeah
it's
for one year and you've been united
states for about
weeks week maximum yeah a week may a few
days even maybe four or five days lara
is here for a few four days already yeah
and i'm here for one week and a half so
tell me how how are things back back in
your country
uh it's getting worse much more worse
than you're you're living in kiev yeah i
was living in kiev
and before i was living in nepal it's
kind of far it's the difference it is
and so in nepal it's kind of safe
because
uh it's uh
it's okay it's not so dangerous but kiev
was when this war started and my mom
called me at it was 4 am i was sleeping
i got a call
okay
honey war just started
so you have to do something with it
and
you have to leave the country or
something and
the the biggest problem was i think that
everybody was thinking that
it's gonna end in a few days in two
three days
everything is going to be okay but
um it's been two months already
and it's still getting worse with every
day
people are starving they don't have food
are there
old people
are dying because they cannot have food
they're eating coffee i know a lot of
stories where people were drinking only
coffee
for a month
because they couldn't go out because if
they will go out snipers russian snipers
are going to kill them
and
[Music]
there is a lot of children who also dine
because they need food and they cannot
sleep
when it's cold in ukraine it's really
cold it's not like usa
because in usa weather is really good in
ukraine it's like a winter right now so
imagine during the winter you're
sleeping
somewhere on the ground in a metro
and with your children and you don't
have food
and you cannot go do go out and get
water
and
yeah
it's
something like this a lot of cities are
occupied
uh
kia was also occupied before when i was
in kiev
but right now it's kind of better
there are bombings and things like that
going on
yeah they're still bombings the problem
is that nato don't i don't know why but
they don't want to close the sky i think
a lot of people already know when you
say that our sky is still open for
bombing
and as soon as war started our president
all our country were asking
please close the sky that's all we need
we will handle everything we will fight
everybody is fighting but they didn't
close it's been three months already
like two and a half
and sky is still open
and nobody wanna help us like they do
help us but
the most important things which we need
yes
and
i think
that
everything would uh could end
if uh
sky would be closed
uh i think maybe
war would be when you say sky closed you
mean yes if the sky would be closed what
do you mean by that um okay there is a
sky area
and um
russian military
is in a sky and bombing from the sky our
country so some way to prevent that
yeah and nato has possibility to close
the sky
so russians cannot go cannot fly
and
because that's
the most important
because we fly we fight on a land
we fly we fight or
on water
but uh we cannot fight in the sky we
cannot do anything with the sky all we
need
is to close it
it's so hard because yeah
old people can't buy something food
because when start war um
everyone uh wasn't shocked and run go to
shopping i remind we stay in uh
line uh maybe four hours because we need
some food but when uh uh start us um
when the their line yeah when there was
in the beginning of the line they told
us there no we close yeah because uh
soon start
uh with this
soon everything close and we can't go to
street because
very dangerous there uh in 5 p.m we need
to was at home
and
if we don't uh
uh was at home uh
it's like uh
uh
diversions or something and it's so hard
for uh us people to understand who um
who is who yeah who is a good person who
is not who you can trust and who you
cannot trust
yeah and so
when starts hispanic older people can't
buy nothing because you go to shop and
you can see nothing
only very expensive food
stay in shops
and
this really so hard
and a lot of
puppy cats
people a leaf disease will start
everything people live
as
us animals and
animals die too because they can't eat
or something now
when uh
when
after start war
little time and then people start doing
something with this uh they uh destroy
uh home and uh do it
saved animals yeah our organization and
there is a lot of organization where
they are saving animals because they so
what they are doing they're literally
doing a hole in a wall
to give food to a cat a dog anything
sometimes a lot of times they found dead
bodies of old people there because they
were starving
and also what i know it's also
uh really really bad
in some tea cities
okay so our nationality or national
value is grieve now
we don't use dollars but in some cities
it's uh so impossible to get grieve now
right now because it's really really
went high and it's everything where
products went so expensive bro
everything
really really got so
freaking expensive that people started
to pay with dollars and dollars compared
to grievna
is
five times higher it's like really it's
um a big differences
so people literally for example had
savings for all their life for 20 years
of dollars
and they started to buy bread milk usual
products what you
is really cheap who anyone could afford
with dollars
so expensive like not even five not even
10
more expensive but i don't know like
50 times more expensive comparing to a
dollar
so there's literally cities in our
country where people are paying with
dollars in some way
it's also like crazy when you hear it
and
again that's it it's going on right now
and
don't take me
don't take me wrong but
i can kinda compare what's going on
right now in ukraine towards to what was
going on in a second
uh international war
why because there was a goodness hit
and uh cannot say it is always bad when
you using genocide gonna sight i'm sorry
gonna say it yeah gonna say it is over
but always bad when you know
you don't like some nationality you
think okay so this nationality is bad
and all russians there is uh all russian
tv all russian media show that we are
killing each other they think that
all russian country
all
nationality think that we literally kill
each other they don't believe that their
army came to us because there's so much
fake news everything is so corrupt that
they literally think that we are
destroy our own houses and it's i'm not
even
uh overthinking it's literally true if
you will go on internet and go and speak
to russian people
they're gonna say no no no we don't
touch ukraine we never we
we don't care about ukraine they're just
sorry suckers they kill each other
they're just uh
nazi russian people think that we are
nazi and they want to save us
from us
they don't believe for nothing what
happened here
there because uh my i have uh uh
ukrainian and half of russia my father
russian
in ukraine only my mom and brother and
now we don't speak with my father
because he can believe
you know what happened in ukraine yeah
first time they don't know nothing about
this because uh russia don't wanna show
nothing
they
i remind i
call my father and want to speak with
him and he told me when i start
father my friends die you understand
close with my house bomb i'm very scary
he said me you told me [ __ ] it's not
right
they killed only nazist
because
it's hard to understand
seriously my grandmother
grandfather don't believe for that and
now we don't speak because he told me
you're like
bender
okay um
it's like um
he don't want to speak with me and he
don't believe
and it's so hard to understand
what close people for you your family
don't believe for you what happened with
you
i can't understand this yeah so she
literally lost half of her family
half a sheet half russian half ukrainian
and half of the family lives in russia
half in ukraine
and so literally she called her father
in front of me
and she's like okay dad like your people
russians are killing us like literally
right now in front of me there is like
this surf sirens sirens going on
i cannot go out people are gonna kill me
like i'm gonna be dead tomorrow
and he started to laugh
he started
what what do you mean we don't we didn't
enter in your country it's you so
your father literally told her that
ukrainian people
came to you crazy
and you started to kill
ukrainian people for what so the news is
news news are so fake but it's hilarious
it's not even it's really funny what i
just said
that can you imagine in us you just go
and you what you destroy your own
country
your favorite place in the world
your home
your families are you serious nobody is
gonna do it but
all russian federation literally think
that
what we are doing
is just like you know for fun because we
are crazy or what
but
i wish
you see killing when you're there yes in
your country dead bodies everywhere
really children
old people
usual people you just go and you know
russians
what they do they do your hands like
this
they tie your hands
they kill you
and when you go you see people on a
street with tight hands like this so
they cannot move
killed
so they
it's
it's
i mean
i it's crazy
because it's 21st century everybody's
sitting on tick tock instagram everybody
posting stories you know nobody
think how safe they are because in
ukraine ukraine is really a safe country
i cannot say that it's a really bad
country no it's safe i've been living in
really
unsafe districts but still even in
unsafe districts i was safe nobody ever
came to uh to me and talk talked badly
or asked about anything sexually for
example as a girl
ukrainian people are really respectful
really if you will ever go to ukraine no
bad nobody is gonna come to you nobody
is to talk to you everybody you know
respect their own space because we are
really
if you if you will learn our culture and
our history half of our country was in
europe so we are really really close to
europe um
you know traditional we are really
traditional country and we are close to
europe because uh um before our country
like long time ago was part of poland uh
and the polot is a poland is a european
union so our country is not like russia
for example it's more like poland
because of the history
and um
ukraine has become
more a lot uh
closer with the nato countries right
yeah and i think russia is threatened by
this the whole war started why because
of the nato our president
uh he wanted to go to nato because we
want to be in european
union for eight years already and but
that opens the door that you know moscow
is is a five-minute missile ride away
from
ukraine
so that makes russia feel vulnerable
yeah so that's where this problem
geographically you guys are in a bad
spot
but geographically we our country is in
the middle of a whole europe
and our country is the biggest
the end in any country in a europe
france germany sweden switzerland
anything we are much more bigger so
that's mean that
uh if the
russia count came to us we have border
with poland we have border with any
other countries so they can easily go
through another countries you know if
they already crossed our border why they
cannot let them in
go for example into poland you know
what are gonna stop them if they're
already doing
such terrible things nothing
what they don't have moral
and that's the most important
moral is the most important who you are
your personality and uh
i was always thinking that i'm safe you
know
i was always living in a good family i
have really good family i have
really good friends i
i never was betrayed or anything and
when all this happened
ah
you cannot even imagine i cannot even
imagine
that we
we fight with racism we fight with
success we fight with everything
everything
okay
but
there are war everywhere
well it's also interesting that the
culture the religion the culture you
share a lot of things with the russians
right
yeah you're you're a very similar people
it's true it's true because we talk in
the same language we have two languages
in ukraine national language is
ukrainian and another languages which is
not national is russian so is
we are free people in ukraine we can
talk even in english if you want you
know so it's a choice of every person
what a language he want to speak and
also it's because of history as i told
you before half of our country
was in europe long time ago like right
now it's europe of course before it was
not
and half of our country
was close to like russia federation
if i'm gonna talk to pre about present
right now of course in the past it
wasn't like russia federation in europe
uh so that's why
our country is really different there is
a lot of
stuff but i cannot say that
uh
i cannot say
that
we are similar to europe or russian we
are something in the middle i can say
because of the history
and yes of course
do i love do i like russia in general
yes because i'm not
nazi i'm not no one i still like russia
i
it's a good country there's good people
i'm still a
person who's moral
so
you know
i'm trying still
there is a lot of hate about russia also
but
russia is a big country we cannot blame
everyone for their president government
we cannot blame people who didn't decide
where to live
and um
that's
also a big problem right now
because i understand that it's all about
i don't know government
it's all about some rich people
and uh people like
me and lada we don't actually decide
anything we just run okay war started
okay what we should do run
okay hide
what
and
the only i also i wanted to share with
you
when i came to us
i saw that you act you actually
give a lot of people a lot of money to
ukraine because even when i was in
starbucks i was buying coffee for myself
in the end i saw okay
do you wanna give money to a refugee in
ukraine
and i saw it everywhere
i don't know where all these money are
going
because there is no food there is no
medicine
there is
nothing and i feel like okay let's
imagine if uh
population of usa is
180 million
a 180 million something el yeah
something like that about 200 million i
think i'm not sure but okay yeah um
if at least one person will donate one
dollar
i mean
it's all gonna be good
but
i don't everybody is donating to us
europe donating to us you are say
donating to us all world just helping us
you don't see any of it no i don't see
it because all i see all health we have
is from ukrainians i literally sent
every week money to soldiers because
there's a lot of volunteers and a lot of
soldiers i send it directly they're
telling me we don't have money we don't
have this we need this we need this we
need technic we need you know this stuff
for not getting killed i don't know
what's the name of it you know we need
all these they're literally saying to me
and we have
she have a huge page on instagram she
also donated a lot of um money and
share
information about how to help ukraine
but
i still cannot imagine if all these
money from whole world are coming to us
why
where where is it and why we are sending
money
we from ukraine literally send money my
mom's sending money all my family is
sending money every every week i swear
i don't know even i don't know any
ukrainian person who didn't
send money or buy
who bought anything for our soldiers
and
so it's also interesting where is it all
going or where is all money
uh
why
all everything is so strict and so
strange
why everybody is helping us but in the
same time
they don't
in the same time
they're giving us money in the same time
we are struggling from
not having food
and
the water
uh this is all
you know i cannot
understand how it can be
all in the same time
i asked my few american friends what do
you think about it
and they told me that of course it's all
official of course
they're sending money but
still
it's really strange
it's hard to believe for you right
yeah it is it is hard to believe and it
feels like it's matrix you know i still
don't i don't believe that all this is
happening and
why this is happening and
are they really helping us
or
maybe
somebody
wanted to have a war in ukraine there is
a lot of
stories in on internet why is it
happening and maybe everything is not so
easy maybe everything is much more
difficult
um
so yeah
yeah it's interesting the uh
would you want to go back to ukraine if
it is
becomes part of russia
no never never um no
uh we are so free um i don't know about
other countries their mentality but
ukrainian people are so
about freedom that literally in our song
we have
yeah you know what's
national traditional song of uh your
country
yes yeah
literally in our him there is saying
that we all that we all the time we are
going to be free why because
uh
our history was that uh
all the time they wanted to take part of
ukraine and we have always revolutions
we have we had even revolution eight
years ago when ukrainian people stand
in a middle of a country
and kick the government out and went to
european union because of how
how much freedom is inside us
so i will never ever
come
to a country or to a government
who is like this who press on me every
time i feel pressing on me i always do
the opposite it's who i am and
i cannot say for other people in ukraine
but yeah
we're all about you know
our mentality is um
every some something is going to press
on us
yeah we do the opposite and that's it
because we hate being manipulative as
everyone also of course
everybody don't like being manipulated
and pressed
so
if
russia is going to take ukraine and
everything is going to be bad i will not
come back
because i don't want to live in russia
what i'm gonna do i don't know
uh where i'm gonna stay i don't know
but for sure i'm not gonna come back i'm
gonna
there are still
uh most of my family is still in ukraine
france are still in ukraine why
not because they cannot go
because they are staying there because
they love their country and they don't
want to leave
that's why
and i came here actually
also
support my country because i cannot i'm
supported in this money i'm trying to
give money to who i can and who i sure
about
and this interview is also
kind of support to my fam to my family
to my friends and to my country
that
we need
to fight back
and
that
no way no way we are going to stand
and listen to
russia what they're going to say nobody
is going to stay in ukraine if this is
going to happen you will see nobody is
going to stay there
everybody is going to live
because it's who we are
and
i guess
i guess we will win
i believe in it because
uh i can't i don't think it's gonna
happen why
because everybody is going to stand
and if i will understand that my country
is losing i fear i are going to come
back
because
i need to be here
and
i'm not selfish i'm trying to be not
selfish i'm trying to hide my ego
and i'm trying to help people because in
my opinion it's the most important
and
no matter who you are
you have to have principles
if you're having if you're having
principles
and moral you're still a person and
you're still alive if you're out of it
you're not a person anymore you're not a
human being anymore
you're just i don't know
object
because
what does it mean to be a person and
human being it's about soul and what's
inside us it's not about how rich you
are what car you have what back what
work what job what
if you have any rich friends or no no
it's about inside
it's about your soul i believe in it
um
that's why
i will everybody is gonna stand for our
country to the end
that's why i don't think that we're
gonna lose because in russia it's not
like this
i know some stories which are really
true
that some soldiers were going to ukraine
they didn't even know that they're going
to ukraine they all they told them
and it's really true some of them it's
really like some of them they told them
they're gonna go just for training
and they came to ukraine to a war and
there were i literally
know one person who were calling
his mother and asking to take him back
and he was 19. they sent 90 years old
boys to take a vo to take a part in a
war
which is also bad
uh 18 19 years old guys 20 years old
guys i mean you have to study
in this age you don't need to war in
this age and they're just changing and
sending saying why we are gonna win
because we are standing for our country
and we have power
we have here something a big soul and
they just came came to us
and
they're just
work for some president
and they don't have soul
and
i always
try to believe that good is gonna win
over the bed
it's not always like this
but
it's on our responsibility
everybody should take responsibility
good and bad in this world and if you're
taking responsibility being bad in this
world then don't judge
that this world is so cruel
yeah
all right
lara and elena thank you so much for
thank you thank you give me some insight
into what's going on over here in
ukraine thank you
thank you very much i hope things work
out for the best for your country
thank you thank you
you